Speaker 1: this.
So to some degree, things are not going particularly
well for the Trump family right now, I mean,
they're still rich and they're still privileged
and they're still powerful, but there are
criminal investigations going on into their
businesses.
Trump Social Media Reach has been replaced
by a blog that nobody reads, etc..
And now Eric Trump and Donald Trump, junior,
two of Donald Trump's kids are doing a sort
of pity me, pity US media tour.
And it's just hilarious and pathetic.
I don't know that I've ever seen a family
that is so privileged constantly claim to
be the biggest victims of everything and everyone.
And I think it all comes down from Trump.
Trump regularly claiming I have nobody's been
treated as unfairly as me.
And so check out some of these clips.
Here is Eric Trump last night on Sean Hannity's
Fox News propaganda show.
And in this clip, Eric Trump whines.
We just get all these subpoenas and they're
treating us so terribly.
And then he just starts telling lies.
See if you can pick up on the lies.
And I know that his mouth moving is a signal
that he's lying.
But there's a specific lie that he tells here,
Speaker 3: estimating his zero experience
son being paid millions.
And all of these other instances now where
he's been caught red handed, lying about knowing
anything about Hunter's foreign business dealings.
Sean, I agree completely.
Listen, I'm on the receiving end of every
single day my father gets subpoena after subpoena.
We do as a family, they attack us.
They go after us for doing absolutely nothing
wrong.
We gave up business when my father went to
the White House.
They did the exact opposite.
When Joe Biden became vice president, Biden
got into business.
But yet every single day my family is attacked
and they look for any karma that's out of
place.
And the prosecutorial misconduct in this country
is out of control.
But yet, because we're Republicans, they attack
us and they do absolutely nothing to the other
side.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So pity me.
Pity us.
But he says we gave up our business when Trump
became president.
No, you didn't.
Donald Trump made one point six billion dollars
during his four years as president from his
private businesses.
Ivanka and Jared Kushner made hundreds of
millions.
I believe it was six hundred and forty million,
if I recall correctly, from the family business.
What are you talking about?
They literally opened the Trump DC Hotel blocks
from the White House while Trump was running
for president in 2016.
And then as soon as Trump was inaugurated,
foreign leaders would come to Trump's DC hotel
and stay there when they would go visit Trump
or visit other diplomats or American officials
in order to ingratiate themselves with the
Trump White House.
What kind of fantasy world is this guy living
in that not only he portrays himself as a
huge victim, he also just tells lies about
the things that they've done and not done.
Then last night, it wasn't just Eric Trump
with Sean Hannity, it was also Donald Trump
Jr with Tucker Carlson on Fox News.
And in this clip, Don Junior says, hey, the
fact that my dad is being investigated, this
is what you expect in so-called banana republics,
not in the United States more.
Speaker 3: But if this was going on in the
Banana Republic, we'd be outraged when it's
going on.
And one of the largest states in America,
everyone seems to be silent on it.
Speaker 1: And so there's two things here.
First of all, is it not possible for Don Jr.
to make a political point without using a
pejorative term about other countries?
Like I'm not saying Banana Republic is like
the N word.
Banana Republic describes a country that's
less developed with political instability,
often an economy that depends on exporting
one thing like a banana or a particular mineral,
a rare earth, minerals, conflict minerals,
whatever the case may be.
So it's not the N-word.
It's not calling a Jewish person the K word,
don't get me wrong.
But it's a pejorative.
It's a derogatory term.
And, you know, he just can't seem to make
any statement without kind of using a gross
term about someone or some other country.
But the funny thing about the comparisons
to developing nations is that the real analogy
between Trump and developing nations is the
one we made during the Trump era, which is
Trump's authoritarianism, Trump's disdain
for freedom of the press, Trump's comfort
with cronyism and nepotism and corruption
and slush funds and all of this stuff.
That's what we are used to seeing in the corrupt
countries of the developing world, often run
by authoritarians or even authoritarian, more
developed nations.
You get the picture.
So there is they seem to stumble across the
fact that there are things happening here
that have an analogy in other parts of the
world, but they just get the analogy completely
wrong.
It's not the investigation of Trump that makes
us like a so-called banana republic.
It was Trump as an authoritarian buffoon,
as president, that made us like all of these
other countries whose leaders Trump admired,
by the way people like to do today, and Kim
Jong un and Putin and the others, in any case,
Eric and Don Jr making the rounds, claiming
to be victims.
And if anybody gets charged in these probes,
I mean, listen, if the Manhattan D.A. charges
somebody, Trump or other Trump associates,
if the New York A.G. probe leads to charges,
we have so much of this insanity to look forward
to.
If there are any charges brought in those
investigations, it will be these two.
Don Jr. and Eric completely unmoored from
reality, claiming everybody is just being
so mean and unfair and everything's just a
scam and a witch hunt.
They stole everything they could while in
the White House.
They stripped the country down to the studs
and now they're saying we did everything right
and they won't leave daddy alone.
In some sense, they're not used to facing
consequences.
So it probably is very confusing because of
the attention that Trump brought on himself
by running for president and becoming president.
The charity was investigated and ultimately
had to pay a fine and be shut down.
Now, there are multiple investigations.
They just don't like their actions, having
consequences.
For a long time, Trump was ensconced up in
Trump Tower in his office or penthouse or
whatever, and people were paying attention
to him, but not like they started to when
he ran for president and even losing the presidency
after having arguably the most disastrous
presidential term in modern political history.
That's a consequence.
And they're simply not used to that.
They're used to being the bullies.
And there may now actually be some consequences.